if I were to ask you why you originally
created your social media accounts you
might come up with something similar to
well to keep up with friends and family
and see what they're doing and stuff
like that and that's not a bad reason at
all in fact it's quite an honorable
sentiment but as society becomes more
dependent on these technologies there's
an ever-growing problem and that is that
our intended use for these social media
applications and what our daily use
actually looks like are often two
completely different things
many of us use social media and our
smartphones compulsively it's like a
nervous tic there's a certain need to
check your phone all the time it's
constantly pulling your attention away
from whatever's in front of you and back
into your other online life and I'm not
gonna say this is ruining the world or
anything like that people are still
showing up to work on time and countries
are still being run decently well I
guess but the effects of this underlying
itch is still measurable and it's felt
by pretty much anyone who owns a
smartphone maybe it's when you're mid
conversation with somebody and things
are going well and you're having a good
conversation and then that itch starts
to happen and you just want to pull out
your phone for no reason even if you're
just swiping between pages you're not
really paying attention to what the
person is saying or maybe it's when
you're trying to write an email or an
essay or an article and it's a little
bit boring and you find yourself
drifting towards the new tab button just
to hit F enter and realize that you
already checked Facebook like 45 seconds
ago and there were no notifications but
you still checked anyways
and that's exactly what I'm talking
about and the weird thing is this whole
thing is an entirely new struggle
humanity has only been dealing with it
for about nine years
Apple rolled out the original iPhone in
2007 but it didn't launch with any
social media apps and it didn't even
have an app store Facebook didn't reach
500 million users until July 2010 a
number which is now 2.3 billion and
Instagram wasn't even invented until
later that year so the relationship
between humanity and social media is
still in its infancy
and we're just kind of stumbling around
hitting our heads on walls trying to
figure out the best way to reap the road
in the usefulness of these apps without
hurting ourselves and our well-being in
the process so if you're somebody who
looks at their phone way more often than
you would like to admit I've definitely
been guilty of this there's actually
evidence to believe that it's not your
fault because most of these apps are
designed from the ground up to be
addictive behind the glimmering promise
of increased human connection is
basically a slot machine in your pocket
where you pull a lever and fun stuff
comes out and these rewards are some of
the most powerful and ancient rewards
that can be exploited in the human brain
social validation and I'm not making all
this up this isn't some giant conspiracy
this is literally how these apps make
money they get paid by third party
companies who purchase ad space on their
platform in the hopes that you the user
interacts with it so the more time you
spend on these apps the more likely you
are to click on or engage with these ads
and the more money these companies and
these platforms make these multi-billion
dollar companies are built entirely by
taking control none of your money none
of your land or your livestock but of
your attention because your attention is
their currency and that's the underlying
issue is we feel kind of helpless to
compulsively use these apps but they're
kind of useful so you sort of need them
they do enhance your life in some ways
and you do use them for useful things
but they're taking away from your life
in other ways because of their addictive
nature thankfully though if you watch
this channel at all I don't make videos
about why we're all screwed and can't do
anything about it
because that's definitely not true you
can find a balance you can maximize the
benefits of social media while not
falling prey to its addictive effects
but unfortunately you can't attain this
sort of freedom by little quick tips and
tricks you know don't use your phone as
an alarm clock only use your phone for
one hour in the day you really do need a
paradigm shift you need to adopt a new
philosophy towards technology use one
philosophy in particular is leading a
sort of silent revolution and it's
helping people regain their focus and
take back control over their lives it's
called digital minimalism
in his book by the same name Cal Newport
defines digital minimalism as a
philosophy of technology use in which
you focus your online time on a small
number of carefully selected and
optimized activities that strongly
support the things you value and then
happily miss out on everything else so
to better understand digital minimalism
and how you can apply it to your life
right now one thing that was useful to
me and understanding how digital
minimalism works is to compare the
philosophies of digital minimalism and
digital maximalism ok so the digital
minimalist doesn't mind missing out on a
potential small benefit that a certain
technology might give them if it has any
risk of decreasing the quality of things
that they already know to be of
tremendous value to them like their
ability to focus contrast this with the
philosophy of the digital maximalist who
believes that any small potential
benefit is worth downloading the app if
they think that Instagram will be a
little bit fun for them or they have any
sort of impulsive reason to download it
they download it immediately if some
application claims to make you more
productive or more connected or anything
they'll just download it without
considering the larger picture of how
that applications daily use will fit
into their lives and whether they really
need it so we've talked about the theory
of digital minimalism but I want to
leave you guys with some practical
wisdom as to how you can apply this
directly right now in your lives so the
number one thing you can do is a
two-fold process the first one is to vet
every application you use and you do
this by asking two questions number one
is what are the benefits of using this
application and number two is is this
the best way to achieve these benefits
so let's take Instagram again for
example I like to rip on Instagram
because I actually deleted it right
after reading digital minimalism so when
I was deciding to delete it my thought
process went like this what are the
benefits of using this application and
my perceived benefits that I was getting
from Instagram probably was twofold the
first one was like I like to keep up
with friends and family and see what
they're up to and by seeing updates on
baby pictures and engagements and stuff
like that I felt more connected to my
friends network and the second
benefit I experienced from Instagram was
probably that it was just fun I guess it
was mildly entertaining when I wanted to
break from something I could check
Instagram and it gave me a little
dopamine hit so then I asked the second
question is this the best way to achieve
those benefits and no they weren't the
best way to achieve those benefits if
staying up to date with my friends is
important to me then the best way to
achieve that benefit is to call them or
text them to set up a time to actually
connect with them on a profound level
maybe not even a profound level just a
genuine level because Instagram is super
superficial super superficial you're not
actually exchanging ideas and
information and getting to know the
person any better so in a way Instagram
wasn't offering me that perceived
benefit that I thought I was getting
from it to begin with secondly there are
way better ways that I can entertain
myself that doesn't completely you know
waste my time if I want a dopamine hit
maybe I should go work out you know
there are healthier ways that I can get
this entertainment so for that reason
Instagram didn't really offer me much
value that I couldn't get in other areas
of my life so I deleted it and since I
deleted it that's one less thing that's
pulling me away and sending me push
notifications and tempting me to go
waste my time on it that way I can use
that gained time and redirect it towards
the things that are important in my life
and that's what digital minimalism is at
its core it's being intentional with why
you use your apps that are on your phone
on your computer and figuring out why
they exist in your life for instance I
also deleted LinkedIn recently because
my perceived benefit of having LinkedIn
was that I was more available to
collaborate within my professional
network I have only ever gotten one job
opportunity from LinkedIn earlier on in
my freelance video career and that's it
on a day to day basis all it's doing is
sending me push notifications and emails
and stuff like that telling me that
people joined my network and I'm like oh
great in my mind I'm like this is more
business opportunity potentially I'm a
well-connected guy it's not worth it it
offers zero value but since I used to be
a digital maximalist I'm like oh there
could be some potential value to having
this app and that's just dumb so the
second way that you can apply digital
minimalism to your life right
is to optimize digital minimalism isn't
all about just deleting every app and
then just facing the consequences of the
ones you don't delete part of it is
optimization so for instance I can't
really get away from Facebook a good
example of this is my facebook group for
this YouTube channel it's doing very
well it's very helpful for people it has
over 3000 members and that sort of
accessibility for a group isn't really
available on any other platform so I
know this whole Facebook group thing is
a useful thing for my youtube channel so
how do I use Facebook and not get
distracted by it and that's where
optimization comes in the main thing
about Facebook that pretty much anyone
would find distracting is the newsfeed
one thing that I did was I installed
newsfeed Eradicator it's available for
Firefox Chrome pretty sure Safari as
well and that replaces the home page the
newsfeed with a motivational quote I
don't really read the quote but it's
just like it just gets rid of the
newsfeed and that's super helpful and
the second thing I did was I deleted the
Facebook app from my phone because that
also has all these options for you know
watching videos and playing games and
stuff like that at the bottom I don't
need that crap I basically only need the
messenger and then when I really want to
check in and you know allow people into
the Facebook group I'll physically type
in Facebook and do that and that's it
that's my entire Facebook experience
it's really stripped down and it allows
me to focus and it has allowed me to
view Facebook more as a tool for my
business rather than a excuse to waste
like 30 minutes watching these viral
Facebook videos so those are just a few
ways that you can apply digital
minimalism to your life right now it's a
dense book it's so rich with great
knowledge and it is probably one of the
best books I've read in a long time in
terms of changing my perspective and I
think it's a must read for anybody who
uses technology on a daily basis
especially for people who are struggling
to pull themselves away from their phone
I'll put a link in the description where
you can pick up your copy of the book
couldn't recommend it enough if you like
this video make sure to hit that like
button because when you like it YouTube
recommends it to more people and you
know YouTube algorithm sees it as a good
video and I think this topic in
particular is really important for
people to see
today's day and age if you're lurking
here consider subscribing because I make
videos like this on a regular basis and
hopefully I can help you out when I
randomly appear in your YouTube homepage
inaction is a slow death t-shirts and
hoodies are available now to buy link is
in the description lots of people are
buying and wrapping it and it is a good
reminder that well inaction is a slow
death it's a good daily reminder to take
action rather than succumb to inaction
and letting your soul decay that's all
for today exciting things coming guys
can't wait to put out the next video
thank you for watching and we'll catch
you in the next video